[Musique]
c est lyon de jeunes traite aujourd'hui
un événement de la semaine
ces derniers jours en effet dans
plusieurs établissements scolaires de
paris le bizutage à tourner mal à
stanislas en particulier un bizuth
contraints de sauter d'une fenêtre s'est
fêlé la jambe ici comme dans la plupart
des classes préparatoires aux grandes
écoles
c'est une tradition de chahuter les
nouveaux en leur imposant en particulier
les traditionnels ports les bizuths et
les élèves en général ont l'habitude de
sauter du des fenêtres du
rez-de-chaussée qui donne dans la cour
comme exercices de sport pour s'amuser
exercice que j'avais des conseillers
déjà auparavant en raison du mauvais
état du macadam
il s'est fait au cours d'une récréation
l'un des bizuths c'est mal reçue il est
entré en classe à 1h30 comme d'habitude
le soir il s'est plaint d'une douleur de
la jambe et effet retourner à la maison
le médecin appelé par la maman de ceux
de cet élève a diagnostiqué une fêlure
au bas du péroné cet accident ne s'est
donc pas passer au cours d'une séance de
bizutage
d'après ce que je sais absolument pas
j'ai vu ce qui se passait j'ai vu ce qui
se passe est grave et de matériel qui
mettait les mains derrière le dos à
quelqu'un ils ont lâché
ils ont lâché le gars il a perdu
l'équilibré et s'est cassé la jambe il
est tombé par terre et se cacher la
jambe
exactement jamais les bras
on est tous vraiment passé histoire
qu'on raconte est uniquement
vous savez la plupart d'entre nous les
cherchons à mieux pourquoi vous même
vous êtes en quatre sections hec bon
vous avez vous êtes un visuel est ce que
vous avez fait comme des stages m'ont
pas grand chose les trucs habituels
parisien chanson le claj est ce que
c'est un cuvelage je suis tout ça je
suis persuadé puis-je vous demander de
me dire exactement ce qu'est un cuvelage
bien je crois que il vaut mieux pas le
définir pour les oreilles quelques plus
délicate
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte ans nous
apporte pas grand chose ne semble pas
connaître les autres c'est pas mauvais
connaître les autres c'est à dire ça
continue marie thé fruits entre pas
patient on connaît les anciens c'est
quelque chose il ya une hiérarchie qui
s'établit en vol et les beats sourire et
les anciens ont ce but une semaine et un
point ils sont très sympathiques avec
nous
nous n est pas chose il y a des
tendances chez certains à on veut dire
des sévices à des brimades des
humiliations et des annonces par exemple
c'est le directeur par exemple les
fameux clash dont on parle par exemple
les à nantes dont les anciens taxe les
bizuths par exemple des coups de
ceinture mais cette année comme les
années passent surtout cette année
ces faits se sont pas produits puisque
nous avions mis en garde tous les élèves
à savoir que toute voix tu fais tous
tendent tous ses vices ou millions
seraient punis d'exclusion définitive de
l'école qu'est ce que vous faites comme
les étages au sont principalement dépens
qu'est ce que c'est la banque
c'est-à-dire faire des tractions de bras
par terre c'est douloureux ça c'est
douloureux pourrait citer une formule
laquelle je vous le dirai pas parce
qu'il ya quelques mots ces deux là moi
je compte merde j'aspire la mousse
ils sont les anciens s'en vont c'est la
vie de château pourvu que ça dure ainsi
de suite ce qui est à craindre c'est que
ces garçons se laisse aller parfois à
des excès surtout dans les brimades et
dans les sévices corporels et c'est
pourquoi les la plupart des eaux tous
tous les responsables d'établissements
les met en garde contre ses excès et
c'est ce qui fait qu actuellement de
plus en plus on vient à l'imiter csn de
bizutage qui dans l'ensemble créé un bon
esprit de camaraderie un esprit de
préparation et et si les anciens savent
observer les règles du jeu ça se termine
vraiment dans la joueurs tout le monde
les anciens je sais qu'ils ont dit a
l'oeil sur un gros et preneurs leurs
calots moi j'ai pris le cadeau d'un
ancien et quand je suis retourné ya dans
ce cas de figure vous avez rendu un
nouveau jeu de tirage pour 30 secondes
toutefois je l'avais complètement fondu
ici c'est à l'ancien je voulais en fait
pas si oui ou non je trouve ça dégradant
pour l'individu
[Musique]
les brimades c'est dirais-je caporalise
caporalise c'est sacré et figaro et
caporalise quoi les gens se vengent eu à
vendre des choses que moi c'est tout et
lorsque vous utilisez vous avez suivi
les visites est maintenant faite en fait
à quoi servent ces traditions créteil le
sorte d'esprit de corps chez les
nouveaux il est difficile d'y répondre
car tous n'accepte pas passivement ces
brimades certains ils sont même
franchement opposés et ils le disent
dans les montres enfin oui parce que le
bizutage des plantes pas d'esprit
solidarité enfin moi je pense pas
j'estime que nos achats que chaque bijou
subi dans son coin puis c'est tout vous
accepter passivement se trouve pas non
seulement pas non non c'est le seul
moment où il puis avoir une domination
sans qu'un autre alors ils en profitent
existe-t-il des sections ici à stanislas
où les bizutages
existe d'une manière plus importante que
dans d'autres camps général les
préparations militaires ont débuté tard
plus important je puis dire que cette
année et tous les tous les garçons de la
corniche avec moi que les bizutages en
corniche ont été inexistants c'est donc
surtout dans les classes préparatoires
aux carrières militaires que le bizutage
est le plus fréquent un ancien qui
prépare la valve nous explique pourquoi
est ce que vous êtes pour la suppression
des bizutages absolument pas absolument
pas parce que quand on est un bizuth ça
donne une cohésion au début le début de
l'année étant donné que c'est très court
ça dure jusqu'au 15 octobre
ça permet aux hobbies ou justement de se
connaître de colère des anciens ce qu'il
ne pouvait pas se produire si on si on
se réunissait pas ça aide à la
connaissance mutuelle et retravailler
ah oui c'est absolument nécessaire à mon
avis est ce qu'il n'ya pas un esprit de
vengeance et à dire est que les
anciennes font pas subir aux jeunes ce
qu'ils ont subi eux mêmes quand il était
bizuths et ainsi de suite ce qui fait
que ça s'arrête jamais non puisque je
vous dirais même que chaque prêtre dans
chaque préparation il ya une journée
quand on n'a pas la journée d'inversion
c'est au tour de bisous des bisous des
bisous télé anciens quand vous voyez
s'il y avait une question de vengeance
des bisous ce jour-là en profiterait
pour se venger des anciens alors ça se
passe toujours dans la bonne humeur
mais ce raisonnement peut conduire loin
sous prétexte de virilité
ne risque-t-on pas de passer le seuil de
la brutalité gratuite
un bizuth lui aussi une classe prix
militaires et nous n'avons plus qu'un
registre et le témoignage nous donne son
point de vue ce qui s'est passé pour ce
garçon
qu'est-ce que vous organisez vous
l'aurez vu la sicile entré dans la
marine et 7 voire sortait l'arrêt 50 n'a
aucune raison de faire voir si les
visiteurs sont interdits dans les écoles
militaires sont là où va-t-on intimidé
modèle de supporter l'impôt de sud est
qui le faire laval les bodin's sens
vraiment une âme signer à l'intérieur de
la promotion donc c'est très bon y'a pas
un peu de sadisme dans la vie ce jour là
je vous prépare activement faire sauter
un garçon deux mètres cinquante exprès
pour les faire casser la jambe parce que
l'année dernière et l'éloignement
certainement pas penser que c'est un
critère à partir duquel on acquiert
vraiment une certaine maturité moi
vraiment que c'est fait vous donner
véritablement un homme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]